[Music]
and tortured nutty news oh no or turn
nanny is this some [ __ ] [ __ ] like
they torture the nanny and beat him up
in slavery and [ __ ] Oh two couples
kidnap a teenager and tortured her in
revenge for snitching on their friend
over a stolen car there's so many [ __ ]
in this story building the cart is bad
and then snitching is bad and then
babies a couple of didn't even steal a
car it was their friend that saw the car
the thief couples but being the
responsible homie you got a back your
homie up I can see that that's true cuz
cuz snitching is wrong so so that's why
they tortured her like she is wrong like
in the gang world you know like you
can't go up to a grandmother force if
we're going to accost white you robbing
her like you fought the soot on me [ __ ]
that's what it is though like I think
people confuse what snitching is
bitching is a code of conduct for
criminals it's not let go to conduct for
regular people regular people are
supposed to [ __ ] call the cops and
have a relationship with that exactly so
I don't snitch either my friend's car
got stolen I posted it they're like
you're a snitch like [ __ ] you're from
the [ __ ] suburbs like what do you
know about snitching like you're in
college right now you [ __ ] idiot
there's nothing to do with like any gang
[ __ ] no and it also has to deal with
like I think like the personal
relationship you have with somebody you
know I mean mind you it like let's say
I'm a civility somebody robbing somebody
else I'm gonna call the cops and my
snitch know I'm a civilian that's what
all souls do but if you caught me
stealing you'll just be like that's not
disappointed in you Joe homie I'm a
snitch I said it's within homie though
because he could just give me a good
lecture
yeah you know yeah like Joe you should
have be [ __ ] stabbing people yeah I
hate like when this [ __ ] 21 year like
20 year old UCLA kid and backpack how
are you snitching on me I'm like shut
the [ __ ] up dude like [ __ ] off that's
the thing is a different type of rule
yes they've done you homies got some
Amen hosts
stabenow man
thank you what did we learn what you
want to eat new got hungry yeah so this
all takes place in Australia Australia
Adelaide Australia fern Manor the victim
19 years old she went to go and babysit
Joshua and Kira's daughter Joshua is 29
Kira's 2809 teen you're still a team I
forgot that that's what I calling her a
theme oh when I think of teen I think
high school kids succeed it's weirding
people yeah like like refers to me as a
woman I'm like or when they tell me man
I hate man okay look I like man because
like it's respectful it's respectful in
making military terms that's just normal
when they call me sir I'm like I know
I'm a knight it feels weird when
someone's like your grandparents age and
then they call you sir oh yeah wait we
night when I get like that I get really
like that's right [ __ ] [ __ ] refer to
your King as the rifle sir like like
when you go into a restaurant and you
have all these like 50 year old waiters
that are waiting on you and like I'm
like that's right dad's don't be calling
me sir so in a couple returned at
midnight that's when they accused the
girl the 19 year olds of being a snitch
and calling her a dog and then they
called Patrick over there friend who's
25 years old and took her over to
Patrick's home where his partner Stacy
23 years old also with her I don't
understand how dog is an insult they
report it it's my job to tell you what
they're reporting what up
is this how do you want your tie so then
they tied up this victim gagged her with
an onion stuffed her in the trunk of the
car and then took her over to Patrick's
house for 16 hours she was tied to a dog
leash and then dragged around she was
beaten kicked burned with the drug pipe
made to smoke meth
to eat pet food clean up her own jokubas
she wet herself out of fear and the
couples filmed all of this on their
phone how [ __ ] dumb nom are they
gonna go to jail for because that's some
terrible show I'll tell you in a second
stupid how many times have they done
this before to where they never got
caught
this is not like first time behavior
they also made the girl believe that she
was gonna be raped and killed they
finally got caught when the victims
roommates mother called police saying
that she was missing and then somehow
they found her they showed up at 9 p.m.
the next day so a poor girl yeah and
then not only that but Stacey's two
children were in the other room during
all of this jeez like what what were
they doing playing with LEGOs [ __ ]
druggies and broke Legos I'm
investigating
I want to hear detectives say that he's
asking the right questions guys I do
this episode of CSI wasn't ordered to do
it play with Legos yeah they're saying
that the victim wasn't even able to read
her statement in court because of all
the trauma issues like her jaw was
[ __ ] up of the onion and lastly I'll
just say I read you guys a quote judge
judge wanted violence and depravity
simply beggars belief that some of you
could treat a fellow human being this
way strikes at what underpins the
essence of a civil society namely our
respect and dignity of our fellow human
beings so Josh was sentenced to 15 years
and seven months with no possibility of
parole for nine years and he was
believed to be the instigator and the
one that did the most of the torturing
Kira was sentenced to ten point five
years no possibility of parole for six
years
Patrick was sentenced to six years and
seven months with no parole for four
years Stacy was released with a $500
on a good behavior with a possibility of
two years if she gets in trouble again
what what Stacy pardon all of this she
was a girlfriend Stacy yeah she's the
mother of the two children that were
there like a long ways but she's an
accomplice right yeah she probably did
some [ __ ] probably but she only gets
away with a $500 fine maybe the victim
said she didn't do anything
yeah yeah so this is Joshua and Kiera
oh she is [ __ ] gross she looks crazy
she looks like a gremlin yeah this is
the first couple that the victim was
babysitting their daughters and this is
the other couple Patrick and was her
name Stacy yeah yeah they're the ones
with the two kids so who was doing the
torturing the gremlin [ __ ] I think I
said Patrick right he was the one that
did most of it so then here are some
photos of her injuries damn do it baby
I'm so sorry
yeah so they got their friend in trouble
because she told on them how did they
know that she snitched that's what I
want to know they just assumed I don't
know how they found out maybe she talked
or pride or just and his Patrick the one
that stole the car no so the way they're
reporting it is that Joshua and Kiera
found out that the victim some reports
are saying that she told a friend who
then told police or that she told police
that another friend like someone else
that's not even involved in this was the
one that was involved in in a car theft
not [ __ ] I wasn't even there just to
my understanding now how did they find
out like this she'd get away like what
happened oh because of the hurt the
victims roommates mother called police
and then somehow their calendar you
think this was their way of like
tricking her to come over to babysit
their kid and then wish she was there
that's when they [ __ ] her up well no
she babysat their daughter and then at
midnight when they cut when they got
home is when they did all of that
weirdos maybe they made up in their
[ __ ] meth head brains maybe but we
still need this is where she was kept
and these are oh wow
is that like a car batteries Wow they
electrocuted her they report that
it's crazy what humans will do to other
humans that's crazy this is a lighter oh
that's what they were recording their
views on yeah that's like a horrible man
this is the victims hair I think you're
in the trash I hope she recovers in
their kitchen
I still traumatized yeah magic James for
life for like a couple days I mean I did
that on no but I mean you guys weren't
tortured was it dry dog food or wet dog
food
Josh would like it maybe what I would do
I'd like to say if the happens me I got
out of that situation I try to get
revenge I would tie them up and I would
take that axe but I would blindfold
myself and then try to start swinging
hopefully I get them so I don't have to
see the horror that I created but I'll
just well you're when you take it off no
no no I'm away for that and then I'm
gonna look for the doorknob and they'll
walk out so I'm not mentally scarred
from it but I know I got my revenge what
did you accidentally injure yourself but
do you take a swing and you end up
hitting your foot how do you do that
we are they tied up they're tied up and
I'm gonna be in the direction that
they're at and then I'm gonna just walk
forward and do this it's like a pinata
I'm not gonna see it though as long as I
don't see it I'm good you should just
look for a nail gun in the tool kit how
to swing an axe and hit your foot David
we're probably like are you kicking well
sweet you kick up and you accidently I
don't know if it'll be this guy he goes
like this is David just have a bone now
he's like this let's go
okay hey guys would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos and check it out up here
[Music]